first we found that the Minneapolis
Police Department routinely uses
excessive force often when no force is
necessary including unjust
deathly force and unreasonable use of
tasers
MPD officers discharge Firearms at
people without assessing whether the
person presents any threat let alone a
threat that would justify deadly force
a review found numerous incidents in
which MPD officers responded to a
person's statement that they could not
breathe with the version of you can
breathe you're talking right now
we also found that MPD officers failed
to intervene to prevent unreasonable use
of force by other officers
indeed as outlined in our report years
before he killed George Floyd Derek
Chauvin used excessive force on other
occasions in which multiple MPD officers
stood by
and did not stop him